like night night always brings out the
highest performances
not to mention flashiest costume that
was not an understatement
Monday's Dancing with the Stars was
super spicy starting off with Ryan
Lochte who got the internet fired up
with comments about how excited he was
and just when we thought things couldn't
get any steamier Jana Kramer kicked it
up a notch and delivered this sizzling
routine arguably the sexiest in Dancing
with the Stars history
but ultimately this is a competition and
someone had to go home amber and Max
Calvin and Lindsey the couple leaving
right now is Amber and max
I'm like I'm sad but I feel like I came
really far I've fell in love with
everyone here and everyone's just
amazing and you know the person that's
gonna win deserves a win whoever that is
next up for max daddy duty he's taking
time off from the show to welcome his
first child a boy with fel of Dancing
with the Stars pro Peta Murgatroyd
yeah there's no way come on man he's
gonna be like a month and a half old and
I'm gonna say okay let me see you in
like three months buddy you know it's